no end in sight for Israel strikes on
Gaza these rescue workers in De Al balah
are searching for survivors as Rockets
Target residential
zones a family home near Han yunes is
hit by an Israel
rocket local hospitals are overwhelmed
and lack essential
supplies patients are treated in
hallways and on
Floors
shelling in rafat 2 where the Israeli
Army had earlier instructed civilians to
evacuate
to all civilians are being targeted
those staying peacefully in their homes
are being targeted we wake up every day
in a disaster tragedy and pain we are
not safe and don't feel secure even the
safe zones are not really
safe life grows even harder here food is
limited water scares and communication
and electricity often
interrupted and there appears there is
no way out Axel zovich
alaz make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer